[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
I hope everybody's
having a great week.
If we haven't had the chance
to meet at a hangout before,
I'm Rachael.
It's so nice to meet you.
Let us know if it's
your first time joining.
If you want to say
hello in the chat so
we can all welcome
you in as well.
This is our open space to chat
about data science leadership,
questions you're
facing, and getting
to hear about what's going
on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so if you haven't
been here before,
every week, we feature a
different data science leader
as my co-host here to help
lead our discussion and answer
questions from you all.
So we are all
dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody
and love to hear from
everyone no matter
your level of experience or
background, or area of work.
It is also absolutely OK to
just listen in if you want to,
but there's also three ways you
can ask questions or provide
your perspective too.
So one, you can always jump in
by raising your hand on Zoom
and I'll be watching
out for that.
Two, you can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a little star next to it
if you want me to read it.
And I can call on you to
introduce yourself and add
some context otherwise.
And then third, we
have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And Tyler already shared
that in the chat right now.
And so we do share the
recordings of each session
to the Posit YouTube.
So you can always go back and
rewatch or share with a friend.
But with all of that,
welcome everybody.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
And thank you so much Nick for
joining us, the co-host today.
Nick Pylypiw is
Chief Data Officer
at Cape Fear Collective.
And Nick, I'd love to have you
introduce yourself and maybe
start off by sharing a little
bit about your role and also
something you like to
do outside of work.
Sure.
So my name is Nick Pylypiw.
I'm the Chief Data Officer
at Cape Fear Collective.
We are, yep, Cape Fear movie.
People are always like, is
it Cape Fear like the movie?
It is based on--
so Cape Fear region is that
southeastern North Carolina
region, Wilmington, if you're
familiar with that area.
We are nonprofit based
out of Wilmington
that's really focused on the
state of North Carolina now.
And we're really
looking to use data
to move the needle on
these social impact issues,
social determinants of health.
My background is more in private
sector data science consulting.
So I worked for a
couple of consultants
and was doing work
with Southwest Airlines
and Proctor &amp; Gamble, and
Lowe's, and Baltimore Ravens,
and Cincinnati Reds, and a
bunch of different organizations
and really looked at
this as an opportunity
to make an impact in the state
that I'm from and that I love.
Some things that
I do outside data
is just building
stuff in my yard.
I'm building a porch
now, screened in porch in
the back of my house.
I'm into music and surfing
and just hanging out here
in coastal North Carolina.
Nice.
Well, thank you so much,
Nick, for joining us.
And it's really
impressive to hear
your journey and all
the different types
of organizations that
you've worked in.
I know from your bio, you
were once a teacher as well.
And I'm curious to hear a
little bit about that journey
into data science.
Yeah.
So I did get my undergraduate.
I got an undergraduate in
math and math education.
It was a double--
dual major and taught high
school math for a couple
of years, geometry
and AP Statistics.
And found myself
really every day
in class with these
AP Statistics kids
talking to them about, here's
why statistics is so cool
and here's all the awesome
things you can do with this
and the applications
and realize, of course,
they're like, yeah.
All right.
Whatever Mr. P.
And really realized that
I was talking myself
into going back to grad school.
So I came home one
day and told my wife.
I was like, I think I
want to go back to school
and get my master's
in data science.
So I went back,
left the classroom,
went back to the
NC State Institute
for Advanced Analytics and
got my master's degree there
and then went into the
data science world.
And I haven't really
looked back since.
I still miss teaching
sometimes, but I
get to do a lot of teaching
in my leadership roles
in my organizations as well.
So I've got a lot of
junior devs and I've
got six data scientists on my
team at Cape Fear Collective.
I've had a number of interns
and volunteers over the years
that I still get to scratch that
itch for teaching a little bit
just outside the classroom.
I was just going
to ask you what
does that teaching look like
now within your organization,
like helping new users learn.
Yeah.
Code review, just scaffolding.
A lot of the things--
I like to say that I can
teach anybody to code.
What I can't teach people
to do is be curious
and think about the
kinds of things they
should be asking on a project.
So a lot of times in a project,
especially with a junior dev,
I'm showing them
my thought process.
I'm thinking out loud and--
a lot of times they'll--
Hey, I've got this error
and I can't figure this out.
It's like, all right,
let's screen share it.
It's like, all right, first
of all, what's the error said?
Well, I didn't look at it yet.
All right, well, that's
the first thing to do,
is look at the error.
Because these things sometimes
tell you exactly what's wrong.
Sometimes they're not.
Some of the errors are
less intuitive, especially
depending on
programming language.
But we are an R shop so we
do a lot of code review.
And a lot of it's just, what
are you expecting it to do?
Is this what you
expected to happen when
you wrote this line of code?
It's like, well, no.
So I think a lot of it is
just that modeling my thought
process out loud
for them to see,
here's how someone who's
been doing this for a while
thinks about these things and
approaches these solutions.
I feel like I
have a lot of power
here when I get to ask these
questions in the beginning
as we're waiting for
them all to come in.
But just a reminder to
anybody who just joined,
you can also use Slido if
you want to ask anonymously
or can raise your
hand here on Zoom
or put it in the Zoom chat.
But Nick, something
I wanted to ask you
is, I know you've worked at
a few different Fortune 500
companies and you
said you've helped
them transform the way they
think about their customer
strategy.
And I would love to
learn a little bit
about how you did that.
I think a lot of people
here in the audience
might be in a
position where they're
trying to get their company
to be more data-driven
and trying to push
new tools forward.
So that would be really helpful.
Yeah, sure.
So as I'm sure you all have
had someone else tell you,
or maybe you haven't,
but a lot of people
are fans of analytics
and data science
if it's confirming what
they already believe.
And one of the things working in
pricing and marketing analytics
at Lowe's, if I went into a
room with a bunch of people who
are marketing lumber and I said,
hey, the promotion that you
did last week did really well.
They're all like,
yeah, all right.
We really like this--
we really like this guy.
And if I was like,
hey, but it missed
these markets and these markets,
then there is a reason why.
No, you didn't analyze it right.
You didn't do this
and you did that.
So people like
data and analytics
if it confirms their
preconceived biases
and beliefs.
But if it counters
that, then that's
where they start poking
holes and wanting
to find fault in it.
So one thing that I've been
very successful in my career
is starting to build that trust.
Find some quick wins.
What are some small projects
we can work on together
that are low stakes
projects that
gets people to buy
into and see like,
OK, now I can see why there's
value in this way of thinking.
So that when that inevitable--
exactly.
Don't start with forecasting.
That's good advice.
When that inevitable
cognitive dissonance comes,
then you've built up some
trust and some capital
with that partner.
That's a great point.
Patrick, I see you
have your hand raised.
You want to jump in?
PATRICK S. TENNANT:
Thanks, Rachel.
And yeah, good
morning, everybody.
Happy to chat with
you again, Nick.
You and I spoke a
couple of years ago.
You may not remember,
but you were
helpful on a couple
of things for me.
And so I appreciate that
and glad to see you again.
I'm wondering about the
comparison and contrast,
similarities as well, of working
in those big corporate settings
versus where you are now in
nonprofit and social services
and that kind of thing.
Personally, I've been in
academic and nonprofit settings
my whole career.
And so it seems to me-- it seems
appealing that people really
have their things together
in a corporate setting
and everything is
well-funded and run smoothly.
And I assume you can
dispel that myth for me,
but I'm just wondering
about your thoughts on that.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think you
nailed part of it
and Marlene nailed a
part of it here too.
Because there's certainly this--
it is a myth that these
large companies really have
everything all put together.
Because the reality is, I
saw some things in every--
all these Fortune 500
companies I've worked in,
I saw things that would
make all of you cringe.
And I'm probably not
going to say any of those
because I don't want to
get myself in trouble,
but things that it's just
like, I can't believe you
run your stack that way.
That is not the
way a $80 billion
company should be running that.
This file should not reside
on one person's laptop.
That should be in a shared
platform locked down,
et cetera.
So there's that.
One of the biggest
differences, though,
for me is in large
companies, people can hide.
There's room-- your errors and
your weak links on your teams
don't expose themselves as
readily as on small teams.
On some of the small teams I've
been on-- my previous company
was 35 people.
And currently at Cape Fear
Collective, we're a team of 12.
And there's no room for
somebody to just not
be pulling their weight.
So I think that's
a big difference.
Another big difference is I
think a lot of the Fortune 500
companies, whether or not
they're actually implementing
it is another thing, but they at
least know that they should be.
They've heard enough times
through all the articles
and through the conferences
and through their leadership
like, you need to
be doing things,
data, KPIs, measurements,
dashboards, et cetera.
They know they need
to be working on it.
There's some
pressure to do that.
Whereas in the social space,
a lot of the stuff is very new
and it's a dramatic
cultural shift.
A lot of the
nonprofits that we work
with are used to
being able to just--
and I'm going to say
this tough for a minute,
they're used to just patting
themselves on the back
and saying like,
we did good work.
And that's good enough.
And the thing is
like, for the funders
and the philanthropic
organizations and grants that
are funding them, it's
not good enough anymore.
You have to be able
to show us that you're
moving a needle, which means
you have to set some KPIs,
measure them, collect data, and
show that you're making impact
against that or else
you're not going to qualify
for that next round of funding.
We can't just do feel
good funding anymore.
PATRICK S. TENNANT:
That's awesome, Nick.
Thank you very much for sharing
and offering that perspective.
Sure.
I see a few anonymous
questions coming in on Slido.
And one was, can you
talk a little bit
about getting your first
role in data science?
Any tips for jumping from data
analytics to data science?
Sure.
And this whole analyst
versus data science thing
is such a weird
ambiguous thing anyways.
If you ask, there's
people that I
know who call themselves
analysts or titles analysts
and they're programming
in Python at R every day
and it's like, that's
a data scientist to me.
And then there's other
people who are like, well,
I'm an analyst.
And it's like, well, are you a
business analyst or are you--
titles all get wonky anyways.
But for me, getting
my first role,
I really wanted to
be somewhere where
I had other folks who
could challenge me
that I could learn from.
I think a mistake that I see
in a lot of young devs and data
scientists is they go
right to a startup or right
to a small company--
and there's nothing
wrong with either of those.
I've done both-- but
you're on an island.
You don't have the
support that you need.
And a lot of these--
I just saw the joke in the chat.
Yeah, that's pretty
accurate right there too.
But a lot of these
larger companies
have support
structures in place.
There's going to be senior data
scientists, senior analysts who
can help you and know
the data sets and can--
so find one of those
large companies
with a solid structure, latch
on to a couple senior devs
and be a sponge.
Just absorb everything
that you can.
And then the other thing that
I can provide that I always
tell people who are trying
to break into this space
is nobody likes
somebody who pretends
like they know everything
because none of us do.
There's power in
saying, I don't know.
And if you apply
for a job on my team
and say that you know how
to do natural processing
languages modeling and I
put you on a project that
requires that skill set and it's
obvious that you don't, I'll
know.
You're not fooling-- you're
only fooling somebody until it's
time for you to use that skill.
So be honest about what you
know and how good you are at it.
If you say you're at
10 in R, I don't even
consider myself a 10
in R. So you better
be really good if you say that.
Marlene, that point
about every time
I think I'm an
expert in something,
I think there's a
graph that shows
that the more you
learn about something
and then you hit a point where
you're just like-- there have
been times in my
career where I'm like,
I'm an expert Excel user.
And then I'll meet somebody
that I work with I'm like, wow.
I'm like a two.
And then I'll be like,
OK, I've learned.
Now I'm like a 7 or 8.
I'll meet someone else
I'm like, I'm a four.
So definitely-- there's
always someone out there
who's better at it than you.
Thank you.
Another anonymous
question was, any advice
for someone working for a
large corporation that's
very resistant to new tools to
progress in the data science
world?
Yeah.
Brush up your resume.
No.
I think it's a
hard thing moving--
someone else made
the point earlier
that big ships turn really
slowly or something like that.
And it's true.
Yeah, I think other than
just keep beating the drum
and keep trying to prove
value, unfortunately,
a lot of these companies
just sometimes it's
going to take way more
than you to get it.
So what I do or what
I recommend to people
is when you're
interviewing for that job,
make sure the
questions that you ask
are hinting at what
that data culture is.
One of the questions that I
think is a really good question
to ask is, what is
a model or a process
that your team has
built that is currently
being used for the company
to make decisions on?
And you'll be really surprised
to hear the wide variety
of answers to that question.
Because it really obvious to
hear someone's like fumbling.
Like, oh, we built
this thing but it never
got implemented
because of whatever.
Or we've been working on this
thing for a couple of years
and it's never quite gotten
the traction that it needs.
And there's going to be
other teams that are like,
oh, we've got this thing that's
helping with our search engine
optimization and we've got
this other model that's
out there that helps determine
where we build new locations.
And what you hear there
is, this is an organization
that is putting their
money where their mouth is.
They're not only hiring
people to build these models,
but they're making business
decisions based off that.
So I think-- yeah, I
don't really-- yeah.
I'll leave it there.
Thank you.
Just to give us a little
bit more context to you
on some of the work that
your team does today,
I thought it might
be helpful to hear
a little bit about the
community data platform
or maybe an example of a
problem your team is solving.
Sure.
So one of the problems that we
hear a lot or one of the issues
that we hear a lot is
there's not data for that.
You have-- so
organizations are really
working to build data capacity
across these nonprofits.
There's 1,200 nonprofits
in New Hanover County
and there's no
shortage of passion.
They all think they're doing
good work, and they are.
But there's no
real data capacity
to understand what's the value
in generating a hypothesis
and measuring data,
collecting data?
What we always hear
is I'd say, well, hey,
you've been doing this
thing for 30 years.
How's it going?
How is it working?
And they're like, well, people
really like our food boxes
or whatever.
It's like, OK, that's cool.
Is it actually moving the needle
on food insecurity or hunger,
or health issues
in your community?
They're like, well, there's
not really data for that.
I'm like, oh, let's
see about that.
So one of the
first things we did
is we pulled in Census
Bureau data, Bureau
of Labor Statistics,
CDC, FHFA, and all
these publicly available
data sources that,
for us as data
scientists, are really
easy to grab because we know
how to use an API to go do this,
we know how to scrape a
website, we know how to search--
google specific terms
that are going to lead
us more successful results.
But for the average
nonprofit community leader,
they don't know
how to use an API.
They don't use Python.
They don't know
any of this stuff.
So for the first time
ever in our community,
we really have this
holistic 360-degree view
of what a community looks like.
And the way we're using
that is to do things like,
you've got a nonprofit
who wants to do something,
here, we're going to find
a metric that works for you
and help you build a
mission around that.
We are going to
decrease children
in concentrated poverty
in this neighborhood
by 5% over the next 10 years
and we need $200,000 to do that,
or whatever.
That is a statement that
is impossible to make
without understanding how
many people currently live
in that situation, what
the current projection is
for that neighborhood, and
what are reasonable decreases
for that metric.
So a lot of our work
is really around that,
but there's some
other larger projects.
One that I'll talk about--
I'm actually going to
drop this link in here,
is this awesome video
that we just put out.
It walks through this.
But the Michael
Jordan Foundation
just put these two
clinics in Wilmington.
Michael Jordan's
from Wilmington.
And he wanted to put them
in areas where they're
going to make the most impact
for low income marginalized
populations.
The hospital system
said, that's great.
We know a lot about
chronic disease
and we know a lot about
health conditions.
We know very little about the
social determinants of health
that you've been studying.
So help us figure out, from a
data perspective, specifically
where these clinics are going
to make the most impact.
So that's our flagship
project and one
that we're really proud of.
This is North Carolina.
That's a great video
to check out too.
Thank you.
Morris, I see you had asked
a question in the chat
a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in next?
MORRIS JOHNSON: Yeah, Thanks.
No.
I think he just answered
it, partially at least.
Yeah.
I'm working at a nonprofit
and I'm a social worker.
Transformation is always
really the big question.
How do we measure that?
That's what we want.
We're pretty good
at tracking outputs,
but the outcomes and
it's a little bit more
difficult. So yeah.
But these are helpful.
Thank you.
Yeah.
And that's actually a question
that we struggle with a lot
too, so I'm glad
you brought that up.
Because a lot of times, it's
not fair to say, hey, food bank,
it's on you, food bank
of New Hanover County,
to turn this area into a
non-food desert by yourself.
And not only that,
but the lag in
data is such that the USDA only
classifies these food deserts
every five years.
So it might be five,
10 years before we even
know if you've moved the
needle on this macro metric.
So what we try to do is we try
to tie these micro data metrics
to those leading indicators.
So we might not know the Census
Bureau data for another two
years because of
the lag, but what
we do have is this real-time
emergency department
data or real-time police data
that we have for our region.
And if we can find
the correlation
between those things, then
what we can do is we can say,
we can see a signal here
at a right now level
that we know is tied
to this macro level
and then we can
hypothesize that you're
moving the needle at
this greater level
that you haven't been
able to measure before.
Another question that was
asked anonymously a bit earlier
was, how do nonprofits think
about the substantial costs
of a data team?
Are these getting more common
with the trend of needing
to prove moving the needle?
Yeah.
I mean, the reality
is it's unattainable
for the average nonprofit to
have a data scientist on staff.
But that's OK because
that's one of the things
that we're hoping to do.
Because part of our business
model is we don't need--
Catholic charity missions of
Wilmington, North Carolina
doesn't need a full-time
data scientist.
All they really need is
40 hours with somebody
on my team to help kick start
the way they think about data.
So instead of saying, hey, every
nonprofit in North Carolina
needs to go hire
a data scientist,
it's, how do we
become that knowledge
hub that through contracts,
through pro bono contracts--
over the last three years,
we've done $2.8 million
in pro bono data
science consulting.
So what that looks like
is somebody on my team
sitting right next
to a nonprofit,
looking at their sales force
or looking at their Excel
or downloading their
data and saying, hey,
did you know that
15% of your clients
are from this neighborhood,
but that actually
the majority of the need
in our county is over here?
And they're like, never
really thought about that.
It's like, OK, cool.
So maybe like put
some flyers here.
And let's try to make sure
that your services are--
that's something that they'd
never really had the ability
to do before because turning
addresses into latitude
and longitude coordinates and
matching it with Census Bureau
data is out of reach for a
lot of them, all of them.
How did you start thinking
about the different data sets
that you might start using?
I'm trying to also
imagine for people
who are working
in a company too,
there's probably so much
data within their company
that they don't know how
to use or where to get.
Yeah.
I mean, I wish I had a
better answer for it,
but the reality is I just
started grabbing stuff.
I like to say I've never
met a data set in this space
that I didn't like.
And that's still true.
Even though we've met
some garbage data sets,
we still bring it
all in because we
think that the triangulation
and the whole combination of all
these different data sets
really adds to the story.
And I'll give you
an example of this.
We're talking to a hospital
in New Hanover County.
And I did see a question
about, is it just
Eastern North Carolina?
We're across the state
now, but we started there.
So majority of the
work that we do
is still Eastern North Carolina.
But we had a hospital
who was looking
at doing some outreach
for COVID testing
and they were looking
at where do we
need to put the Spanish fliers?
We've got these English fliers.
We've got TV ads.
We've got signs.
Where do we need to put fliers
that are written in Spanish?
And we told them, well,
you need to put them here.
And they're like, well,
based on the Census Bureau
data, only like--
I'm making the numbers up.
I can't remember off
the top of my head.
But only like 5%
of the people there
are Hispanic or English
second language, or whatever.
And it's like, OK,
that might be true,
but for reasons that we don't
have to discuss in this call,
a lot of times
non-English speakers
are de-incentivized to
fill out the Census Bureau.
And actually, there's
a fear factor there
and everything else.
So the Census Bureau
historically undercounts them,
number one, and then, number
two, based on your data,
you have a large portion of
Spanish speaking patients
who live in this area.
So there's a mismatch
between the Census Bureau
data and the hospital data.
Who's right?
Who's wrong?
Don't know, but it's
like, if you only
had one of those data sets, you
might make a decision that's
not actually the right one.
So by having them both, you
have a more complete version
of the story.
Thank you.
Elaine, I know Nick just
answer the first part
of that question, but would
love to have you jump in
and ask the second part.
ELAINE MCVEY: Yeah.
So I'm just-- I'm curious
because it sounds like you're
regionally focused
with this model
of a combination of contract
and pro bono central support.
How does that work in terms
of getting to know people,
helping them identify needs and
so on in your mind versus maybe
focusing on a particular
type of nonprofit
and working in a larger
national international scope?
Yeah.
It was really natural for us.
We had some really early
success in the first year
where people were--
in New Hanover County, and
that's that Cape Fear region.
Like we love this.
We love it.
We started seeing like, all
of a sudden people in Raleigh
are asking us and people
in Charlotte are asking us.
And we're like, are we
going to go statewide?
Are we going to go regional
if the whole Southeast
in North Carolina?
Are we going to be
like Eastern Seaboard?
When does this stop?
And it auto-corrected
itself because we
got to the mountains
of North Carolina
and people up there all of
a sudden were just like,
I don't care where you're from
in Eastern North Carolina.
You don't know anything
about us up here.
So there still has to be this
boots on the ground connection
to the region or else--
For the same reasons we
talked about building trust
and capital in a
Fortune 500 company,
if you think about the
state in that same way,
if you're from the
beach town and you
try to go up into the
mountains and tell them
what they don't know about
their public health crises,
you're going to get run
out of there with a stick.
So I mean, you still have
to build these connections
organically.
That's limited our
business plan in a way
that I think makes sense,
not in a bad way like, oh,
we can't do that.
Now, the other thing is
we've made it very clear
that we want to work by, with,
and through, and not around.
So areas that already have--
if there's an area in
North Carolina that
has an organization
that does what we do,
we definitely don't
want to go in there
and say like, we're
going to replace you.
It's how do we work together?
How do we start sharing some
tools on some of this work
because we understand
that you're here and we
can't-- there's plenty of
work for all of us anyways.
So we don't really have
our sights set on any--
there's so much work in
Eastern North Carolina.
Here's a stat for you.
If you carved North Carolina
in half down Highway I-95
and you just looked
at the East part of it
and made that a state, it
would be the poorest state
in the country.
So no Raleigh, no Charlotte, no
Winston-Salem, no Greensboro.
If you just looked at
East part of the state,
it would be the poorest
state in the country.
So I mean, that's the
level of challenge
that we're working with.
So we have our hands
full with just that,
but definitely are opening
our eyes to the whole state.
Bill, I see--
Did I answer your question?
I'm sorry.
I think I did.
ELAINE MCVEY: Yeah,
I think that aspect
of working with people
who trust you and trust
that you know something about
their domain is a good--
that's a good point.
That makes sense.
And it makes me laugh because
I know North Carolina.
Also makes sense
from that regard.
Bill, I think you
asked the question
in the chat a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in next?
And I can read the
question for you.
It was, Nick, maybe you
stated this earlier,
but are you using
cloud-based resources
or on-prem infrastructure?
And then the second part
is, have you grown your own
or do you use Posit or some
other service provider?
Yeah.
So we're using-- like I
said, we are an R shop.
So we're using R
Shiny in Shiny apps.
The community data
platform that we've built
is a MySQL based
product that is in AWS.
So we're using S3.
So a lot of the stuff that
we're using is cloud-based.
And we just made that decision
early on because it was just
so much easier to scale it.
And cloud storage
is so cheap now
that it just doesn't
really make any sense.
So definitely excited to
see about the changes that
come with Posit.
And I'm not just saying that
because this is a Posit call
because, I mean, I'm an R guy.
I love R. I've used Python.
I've used SAS.
I actually started
my career in SAS
and quickly switched
to something else.
But yeah, that's
what we're using.
Thank you.
Marlene, I see you have a
question in the chat too.
Do you want to jump in?
Oh, sure.
Hi.
Hi, Nick.
Hi, everyone.
Love your talk so far.
I don't think there
has been a single one I
haven't enjoyed this.
I feel repetitive every time
I get a chance to say that.
I'm always curious.
You seem very articulate
and obviously you
know your stuff with analytics,
but I'm always curious,
is there a skill set
or talent that you
think most people wouldn't
associate with analysts?
Like a preconceived
notion about we're
just nerds that sit in
cubicles and don't know
how to interact with people.
What's a talent or
skill set that you
think people should
probably know, it's probably
handy to have, that
maybe it served you well
that we wouldn't think of
as analysts and scientists?
Yeah.
I think it's going
to sound cliche,
but just like
listening and being
able to have a conversation.
I can't hire robots.
There's no position
on my team for robots.
And these days of we
keep the nerds over there
and we give them their
assignment under the door,
and don't touch them.
Leave them alone.
Let them do their thing.
Those days are over.
There's no space for
somebody who does that.
And most companies, maybe
some very specific niche
tech spaces there are.
But in general, listening and
being able to go back and take
feedback and not be offended.
Because a lot of
times, there's this--
I was actually just
laughing at this meme
I saw on LinkedIn
where it was like how
people see a data scientist.
And it's a bunch of
people sneering over
at this alien who's typing
in a foreign language.
And it was like, how data
scientists see everyone else.
And it's like they're
all like cavemen
and they're all hank
waving these clubs around.
And there's some truth
in that, and it's awful.
But it's like, there's
been so many times
where I've got out of a
meeting and somebody said like,
oh, well, they don't
really know what they want.
I'm going to build
them something anyways.
It's like, OK, that's a
route that you can go.
That's a possibility, but
where does that get you?
That gets you now you've
spent a whole sprint
making a development
that you know
they just said they don't want.
And now you're going to
be frustrated and double
down and say, now they really
don't know what they want,
but it was really just
because she didn't listen.
So taking those extra
moments to really listen
to what they're saying
and not-- and there's
a difference between
listening to the question
they're really
asking and finding
the question you want them to be
asking and what they're saying.
And that's a subtle difference
that I think needs to be made.
Listening.
Cool.
Thanks for that.
Have you had to
coach people on that
or any tips for us on that?
Yeah, definitely had to
coach some people on that.
I think a lot of times
it's just I definitely
have the management style of
just modeling and scaffolding
that behavior.
I feel like it's easier
for people to learn it
if they just see
interacting with clients
in a respectful way
and listening to them
and asking those
probing questions.
Because you can
just say like, hey,
make sure you're listening
to the client and make sure
you're really asking
those probing questions.
But it's like, what
does that look like?
Absolutely.
Miles, I see you have
a question in the chat.
You want to jump in?
Sure.
Hey, Nick.
Thanks for doing this.
So when you were talking about
the difference between East
Carolina and the
coastal Carolinas
and how do you organically build
those relationships because I
feel like maybe there
would be maybe not
resentment but some
standoffishness of like,
OK, this is a coastal guy.
He doesn't get it.
He doesn't know what's going on.
So how do you build that
trust and that relationship?
Yeah.
And it's even worse
when they find out
I live in Raleigh
because I actually I
grew up in Eastern North
Carolina on the coast
but now I'm in Raleigh
in the capital.
So then I'm talking to
some of these small towns
and it's like, oh, just some
guy from route from the capital,
from the city telling
us how to do stuff.
If we ignore him
long enough, he'll
go away and start
bugging somebody else.
The same way that we talked
about building capital
in a big company.
Especially with
this line of work,
you'd be surprised at
how much buy-in you
can get if you show
up and you actually
know how to pronounce the
town name and the county name
correctly.
Do you go into Beaufort, North
Carolina and you say Buford.
That's South
Carolina by the way.
Spelled exactly the same, but
it's Beaufort in South Carolina
and it's Beaufort
in North Carolina.
If you go into Beaufort
and call it Beaufort,
you've lost them before even
the first slides hit the screen
because it's just some
outsider coming in here
who knows nothing about us.
So just being able to go
in there and say-- and one
of the things that our
data science team has done
is when you're learning
about a new area, one
of the first tasks that we've
started doing is put together
a deck of just, I want to know
the five worst areas of poverty
in this area.
I want to know the five areas
where there's great employment
parity or great
employment rates, all
these different things.
And through that
exploration, you understand,
oh, there's this town here and
there's this other town here,
and this is this county.
And you learn about that area.
So now when you are
in a conversation,
you can intelligently
talk about that region.
It doesn't sound like
you're just some person
looking at a chart
and saying like,
you need to do this and this.
That's really
helped us to really
just learn about the areas
that we're working in.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for that.
Coulter, do you want
to jump in next?
COULTER: Yeah, sure.
Thanks.
Just a quick
background, I actually
work on a data science team in
my local public health agency
and we quite often
help out nonprofits.
We get tons of requests,
hey, we need some data
but we legally can't get it.
Can you analyze this?
We want some spatial analysis.
But I was just
thinking how cool it
would be if we had a local
nonprofit with the skill
that your organization has.
So I was wondering if you've
ever had a chance to collab
with local public
health agencies
or academic
institutions and what
that relationship was like.
Yeah.
And I'm really
encouraged to hear
that some of the
local governments
are starting to get that
skill set in-house because I
don't think that's very common.
So that's awesome to hear that.
We work closely with a lot
of county governments, city
governments, universities,
definitely UNCW, NC State, UNC,
some folks at Duke and UNC
Charlotte, and some others.
But to be honest, at
first, especially--
The county-- the local
governments are always all in.
They're like, yes, please.
Help us.
Help us figure this out.
There's been some
resistance at first
from some of the universities.
They're just like, who's
this plucky little nonprofit
who's coming in here
and acting like they
can do this data science work?
And then when they
see like, oh, actually
they've got some
people on staff who
have some credentials
and some experience
and know what
they're doing, then
their tune changes a little bit.
But a lot of times--
one project we worked on
was there's a county
in North Carolina that
should be in the MSA
that Wilmington's in.
But because there's a
river between the two,
there's a bridge, it's actually
in the Myrtle Beach MSA.
So we did some work with the
Brunswick County government
because their thing was,
look, 60% of our people
are working in that
county right there,
but we're in this other
MSA in South Carolina who
doesn't care about us.
We don't get any support
from the funding there.
So we're in this
weird ambiguous limbo
space where can you help us make
the case to the Census Bureau
that we should be in this MSA?
So we compiled all
this data and basically
found all these commuting
patterns and residency
patterns and everything else
that basically showed this
belongs in this other county.
TBD whether the Census
Bureau is actually
going to listen to us because
we haven't got that result yet
back, but that's an
example of one of those
projects that we did.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Jamie, I see you had asked a
question a bit earlier as well.
Do you want to jump in next?
And then you all for all
these great questions too.
JAMIE SINTON: Thanks
for the opportunity.
I think I'm getting
the sense that I
may be in the minority in
that data science is not
my primary work.
And so I'm trying to know
enough to be dangerous
about data science just to
interact effectively with you
guys.
And so I'm curious when
you sit down with a client,
like a university, what
expectations do you set
or what deliverable
do you talk about?
Yeah.
A lot of times it's just
knowledge sharing and data
sharing at first.
It's, hey, we'd love to
work with your organization.
Because a lot of
times universities
are the path to opening
up greater data access.
There's financial
institutions, for example,
who are way more willing
to give UNC Chapel
Hill a big pile of people's
credit card transactions
than they are my team of
nonprofit data scientists six
folks sitting on the
coast of North Carolina.
So a lot of times that
conversation is, how can--
we've got a gap to fill
projects that are maybe
too small for you because a
lot of-- these universities
don't also want to sit next
to Cause for Pause and K9s
for Veterans and help them,
not because they don't want to,
but because they have bigger
projects they're working on.
Blue Cross Blue Shield
and other large projects.
So we're filling a need
that you can't fill,
but we need resources
that you have.
So we also have a
couple of projects
where we'll enlist the research
arm of these facilities
because love universities,
love research, love academia.
Things move very slowly in the
university world and too slowly
for a lot of the organizations
that we're working with.
So yeah, that's where
we see that lane is.
When it comes down to
doing a longitudinal study,
we'll kick it over to you UNCW.
But right now we just need
to do some basic analysis.
JAMIE SINTON: And
so you're imagining
taking the place of a university
statistician data management
person or you're coming
in with your own project
and asking the
university for data.
It's usually more
the second route.
Like we--
JAMIE SINTON: Gotcha.
We're not really--
yeah, we're filling-- so a lot
of times, all these counties
have to fill out these community
health assessments every year
or every three years,
I believe it is.
They're mandated by law to
do these community health
assessments.
The universities are totally
capable of doing them,
but they bid for them.
And what you end up with is UNC
has done these and NC State's
done these and ECU
has done these.
And now it's really
hard for these counties
to compare how they're doing
against these other counties
because this other county has
a completely different format,
completely different
metrics they're focused on.
So one of the things
we've pushed on
is, how can we help you align
on a common set of metrics
so that when you're doing
it or you're doing it
or you're doing it
Duke or whoever,
we all are at least looking at--
You're still going to have
room for your own flavor
in your own research
and academics,
but can we all at least agree
that these 10 metrics will
be in every single report,
measured the same way,
talked about the
same way so that it
allows us some level
of knowledge sharing
and comparison.
Like that's something
that we can--
a recommendation we can
make as an outside entity
that none of them are going
to make to each other.
JAMIE SINTON: Interesting.
Toyin, I see you
shared a link in the chat
and just wanted to see
if you wanted to share
a bit about what that is.
TOYIN OLA: Certainly.
So the Census Open
Innovation Lab,
which is a subset of
the Census Bureau,
has been doing a project
called The Opportunity
Project, or TOP,
for several years
where they partner with
organizations in order
to solve real-world
problems with open data.
It sounds like
Cape Fear is really
pushing the boundaries of what
can be done with open data,
but that would be a way
to interface directly
with government agencies
to use the data to solve
problems and develop
data products to help
local communities.
They did have a summit
a couple of weeks
ago that was streamed to
YouTube that gives you
an idea of what's been done.
But the 2023 process is
getting ready to kick off
in a couple of months so
it might be of interest.
Oh, I hadn't
seen that one yet.
I'm going to put
it on my list here.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Nick, I was remembering that we
were first talking on LinkedIn
about Tidy Tuesday.
And I was curious
if that's something
that the team is
starting to look at now
or if you were maybe sharing
data for a Tidy Tuesday project
and maybe other open
source initiatives where
people could get involved.
Yeah.
So as a user, I've done Tidy
Tuesday a couple of times.
I think I did one on slave
migration, one on tennis stars,
maybe one on a couple
of other random things.
I think it's just
such a cool project
to just everyone
rally around a data
set and code for a couple
of hours on a Tuesday.
I'm trying to think about
how to wrangle our data
platform into something
that would be not too
overwhelming for that because
we've got this big SQL
database that has--
I think it's got 170,
180 tables in it.
Obviously, we don't want
to just say like, here,
play around in this big--
because people
will just get lost.
So can we create
like a CSV that we've
joined three of
these tables together
and say like, all right,
you've got food insecurity,
social vulnerability
index from the CDC,
and poverty at a
census tract level.
Go.
What can you do?
So yeah, we're
definitely going to put
a submission in just
how we provide something
that's like the right scale
for an activity of that size.
Cool.
Dan, I see you had a question.
Can I have you jump in next?
DAN SISCO: Yeah, sure.
I just wanted to say awesome,
kudos for still teaching.
I love it when people bring
their experiences in the field
right to the classroom.
I was wondering
if you could talk
at all about why you
chose to keep doing that
and what rewards you see.
Yeah.
I mean, if I'm being honest,
it wasn't really a choice.
I think people who
go into teaching
have a certain personality
where it's just,
I was going to be
teaching wherever
I was going to be at anyways.
Also, I think I learn that way.
Some people learn
best through teaching.
And when I have to explain
something three different ways,
it just cements it my
understanding of it
that much better in my head.
And so I think that's
the thing that I really
enjoy about teaching, is
like if you know something,
you can always tell when
somebody really knows something
if they can explain it a
bunch of different ways.
If you ask somebody
to explain something
and then they say it and you're
like, I'm still not getting it,
and they just like say
the same thing over again,
it's like maybe you
don't get it either.
Like both of us, I
think, don't get it.
But it's like, if they can
use different analogies,
then it's like, all right.
Yeah, I got it.
So I think that is just
part of how my brain works.
And I just enjoy interacting
with people that way too.
Niall, I see you have
a question as well.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
Thanks.
So we get pushback
sometimes for our projects
not being data sciencey enough.
And so I'm curious--
and some of the stuff
you've described obviously
is more advanced, some of it
sounds fairly descriptive.
I'm curious what
those proportions are
and how much that
influences your decision
to take on a project as a team.
Yeah.
Is that pushback from staff?
It's both.
If people are like, that's
not a predictive model, man.
Why are you spending
your time on that?
I was like, well, it's
what was needed, right?
Right.
I think those conversations
are easier for me
when it's somebody pushing
back and saying like,
this model's not
complicated enough.
I'm like, well, I can build
the support vector machine
to do what this
logistic regression does
if you want me
to, but it's going
to cost you another five weeks
of work and it's going to--
the R squared is going to be
just the same or whatever.
So I think that
conversation is easier.
The thing that I think--
I really struggled with when
I was building this team.
So I was the first
data scientist.
They brought me on
in April of 2020
and they're basically
like, hey, we
want to do this cool data thing,
this nonprofit data thing.
I'm like, cool.
What kind of data
sets do you have?
They're like, we
don't have anything.
I'm like, I'm in.
Let's do it.
And they're like, who
else is on my team?
They're like, it's just you.
I'm like, sweet.
I got it.
So as I started
building the team out,
I had to be really honest with
people I was bringing on board
that if you're the
kind of person who
wants to do NLP, bleeding edge,
TensorFlow, this kind of stuff,
this is not the role for you.
We're going to be doing a lot
of logistic regression, K-means,
K-modes, summary, mean
equals whatever type stuff.
So I just approached it by just
being really honest with them
up front.
I said, but what
I can promise you
is there's going to
be a lot of impact
that we're going to make
because it's not a cop out to me
to say there's so much impact
that we can make with just
descriptive
statistics and summary
stuff right now in this
sector that we're just
scratching the surface.
By the time we get into some
of that advanced stuff--
and we were doing some of it.
We've got some pretty
big projects where
we've done some forecasting.
We've done some
more modeling stuff.
But I think that's how
we've approached it,
is just been super honest about
like, this isn't that role.
It's not going to be a
Google engineer role.
DAN SISCO: Thanks.
Yeah.
I remember us talking about
that before in another hangout.
I was trying to remember
if it was Allen who
was talking about it before.
I see Adrian you had
asked a question.
Do you want to jump in?
ADRIAN LINDSEY: Sorry.
Yeah.
Eating my lunch,
but I'll jump in.
No worries.
I can read it too.
ADRIAN LINDSEY: No.
No.
I'll just stay on--
I'll just stay off camera so
you don't have to watch me chew.
You had mentioned a
handful of these projects
where you were
able to really take
advantage of these
open data packages that
seemed to unlock
some of the questions
that the nonprofits were asking.
And I'm just curious how
much of those projects
are shared, if you and your
team maintain a GitHub, if--
I'd really like to
start connecting
some of those dots myself,
just intellectual curiosity.
And I have tried to take
advantage of open sources
in the past and I've had
a few walls so seeing some
that actually go off the ground
would be really interesting.
Yeah.
We do have a GitHub,
of course, but it
is private to our
organization right now.
Not because we want to
hoard the information,
but really just because
we're just not at a state
where-- it's messy in there.
We've got some
cleaning up to do.
We've been going so fast
for a couple of years
that a lot of stuff
needs to be organized.
And we really need
to figure out too
which pieces we're able
to elevate to the public.
We do have a desire to be--
I just put the link to our
community data platform,
didn't hyperlink for
some reason, in the chat.
But that's a public
interface into our--
it's into the back end
of the SQL database.
So go and click around in there.
You can see some of
the sources of the data
that we're working with.
But the thing is, there's
really a couple of partitions
that we have in our
community data platform.
There's what you can see
through this link, which
is Census Bureau, CDC,
all that kind of stuff.
But then there's some
private partitions
that, for example, Wilmington
Police Department arrests.
We don't want that on the
public GitHub or the public user
interface because we have a very
specific agreement with them
that we're not going to do that.
New Hanover County
Schools discipline
reports and progress for
children in public schools
in the county.
That's in a separate lockdown
partition of the community data
platform that we can use
for some of the metrics
we're creating and some of
the analyzes we're doing,
but that we're not going to
expose an endpoint to everyone
else.
So I think absolutely
the end state
would love a world in which
people are pushing and pulling
from our GitHub and saying like,
we want to add this new data
set, and we're like, OK,
here's the conventions
for the data set.
If you put it in
this format, then we
can add it to the
community data platform,
but we're just not there yet.
Thank you.
So one more Slido
question and it
was, what advice do you
have for someone who's
interested in starting their
own data science consulting
company?
So I've known some people
who've gone that route,
and it can be very rewarding.
I will say almost all of them
will also tell you though
that they were able to do
it for a couple of years
and they got burnt out on it.
And the main thing
is acquisition,
customer acquisition
takes a lot of time.
So I mean, just
pitching projects--
And you don't
realize when you're
working for a
consultancy, someone else
does all that stuff.
Someone else goes and finds
all the contracts and says--
you're only seeing 10%
of the contracts that
actually got pitched and signed
and executed and came to you.
Whereas if you're owning
your own consultancy,
you're the one who's got
to market and reach out
to all these things and pitch
30 different things hoping
two of them bite.
So I would just say be prepared
for that part of the slog.
But the advantage is you
have your own company.
You get to work for yourself.
Yeah.
OK, maybe on a--
Project you want.
Maybe on a related note,
one last question for you
because I realize it's already
the end of our time here.
What is one of your favorite
pieces of career advice
that you've ever
received or have given?
Wow.
Just so many.
It's hard to narrow
it down to one.
But if I--
I think the biggest
one is when you're--
remember that the interview
isn't just for the employer.
The interview is for you too.
Ask those questions.
Don't be afraid to dig deep.
Don't be afraid to ask to--
can I talk to somebody who's
on the team I'll be working on?
And not just my manager, like
somebody who's at my level.
Somebody who would
be my peer because I
want to hear from them.
And just really make
sure that it's somewhere
that you want to work.
Absolutely.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Nick, for sharing
your experience and insights
with all of us and
taking the time
to answer all of our questions.
We really appreciate it.
Yeah, I really enjoyed it.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to put my--
I don't know if there's
a follow-up or anything,
but I could put my--
Yeah, I was just going to
say, is LinkedIn the best place
for people to connect with you?
Perfect.
So if we want to share
that in the LinkedIn--
or his link in just a second.
Sorry.
I usually have it pulled up,
but I wasn't quick enough
on my multitasking here.
But I'll be sure to put
it with the recording too.
But thank you all so much
for the questions too.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.